[Music]
it's a historic moment protests that
have quickly grown into a global outcry
for an end to racism the frustration in
the rage it's the past due notice on the
debts owed to black communities for the
last 400 years that demand for change
has found immediate form in the cause
that sparked the fire more than 1,000
people are killed by police in America
every year it is now the sixth leading
cause of death for young black men no
other organization in America is allowed
to act so ruthlessly with such impunity
but given this unprecedented opportunity
for change how can the police be forced
to truly protect and serve
[Music]
America's police are heavily armed
almost every officer is entitled to
carry a semi-automatic pistol it's more
the Department of Defense transfers
surplus weapons to local police forces
the police force in charge of providing
security in Los Angeles's schools was
given three grenade launchers eventually
they returned it but they did keep 61
automatic rifles in a bind resistant
vehicle this has ensured that the police
are not just heavily armed but they
increasingly have come to look more like
a military force than like peace
officers little wonder that police in
America have become a deadly force
almost 8,000 people were killed by
police between 2013 and 2019 black
people who make up 13% of America's
population account for 25 percent of
those deaths they are almost three times
more likely than white people to be
killed by police dr. Philip atiba Goff
is head of the center for policing
equity which analyzes data to try to
understand these racial disparities what
all that research clearly says is that
crime and poverty are not sufficient
explanations for racial disparities in
stops and in use of force so the real
question is what's the rest some of that
are the policies and the culture of the
behavior of law enforcement the CUFI
reform is one that has become definitely
but it's not an easy task for a start
there are about 18,000 different law
enforcement agencies from federal
agencies to state city county and even
school police almost half of them employ
fewer than 10 officers and so when you
talk about police reform what you're
talking about is trying to get 18,000
different entities to change their
behavior that's incredibly complex and
difficult to do law enforcement agencies
for the most part regulate themselves
take for example rules around their use
of force federal law states this must be
objectively reasonable but there's no
single rule establishing clearly what
this means in practice some states and
cities have passed their own laws on the
subject but not many so in most cases
it's left to each police agency to
create an enforce its own use of force
policies if they choose to address it at
all the police are also protected by
strong unions which tend to oppose
reforms so police unions can be
incredibly powerful their job is
essentially to protect the rank and file
from litigation from injury but
sometimes what is in the best interest
of individual officers isn't what's in
the best interest of Public Safety
police unions are very good and
negotiating favorable contracts for the
members but those contracts often
include protections from discipline
which can make it really really
difficult for police chiefs to get rid
of people who they know are bad apples
[Music]
this is how many people were killed by a
police officer between 2013 and 2019 and
these are how many officers were charged
and convicted the disparity is in part
because prosecutors are reluctant to
bring charges against police officers
prosecutors need to win convictions to
advance their careers to convict people
they lead police to testify and police
won't top prosecutors who go after cops
all of which might help to explain the
sense of impunity sometimes displayed by
officers not least the one responsible
for the death of George Floyd one of the
people I talked to over the course of my
reporting that was a sociologist named
Nicole Gonzales Van Cleave she works on
prosecutorial police relationships and
she made an observation that I found
very hard to shake
and that was that during that video you
see officer Chavan looking directly into
the camera as he presses his knee into
mr. Floyd's neck he knows he's being
filmed yet he stares directly into one
of the camera's not even resisting
arrest right now no professor Gonzales
then Cleve observed that that would not
happen if he thought he would be
prosecuted to her mind and to mine -
that was just evidence that he knew that
nothing was going to happen from what he
was doing
offices are also protected from civil
prosecution under the principle of
qualified immunity lawsuits against them
can only proceed if those clear legal
precedents than what the officer was
doing was wrong it's a preposterous bar
to hold somebody to account only when
someone has done that specific thing
before and so what you'll hear as most
performers say qualified immunity has to
go because even the egregiously bad
incidents often get off the hook because
no one ever thought to be that egregious
previously with the obstacles to change
seemingly so entrenched perhaps it's
little wonder there's been a rallying
cry for more extreme action there's a
new call for deep structural reform of
policing across the country asking city
leaders to defund Police Department's
one of the most important things right
now is to understand what people mean
when they say defunded the police there
are some people who by just saying to
fund the police
literally mean abolish law enforcement
the community can take care of violence
that's not the thing that I hear most
commonly particularly from black
neighborhoods but I hear from them is
that the purpose of defunding is to
shift resources from punishment to
empowerment so that they have the
ability to live lives where you don't
have to call the police
you would never send a nurse to break up
a drug narcotics ring why on earth are
you sending law enforcement to go deal
with someone who's overdosing it's a
seductive yet politically divisive idea
but for some forces defunding isn't
enough the only solution to start again
from scratch for years Camden New Jersey
was among America's most violent cities
in 2012 it had the fifth highest murder
rate in the country that's saying yeah
it disbanded its police they shut down
the police force they hired people back
they ended up expanding the force but
when they reconstituted their force they
really paid a lot of attention to best
practices to improving community
relations they wrote a use of force
policy that's 18 pages long extremely
detailed one of the best most detailed
use of force policies in America it
seems to have worked
Camden says the number of complaints
about excessive force has declined every
year in 2014 there were 65 last year
there were three only political will can
determine whether Camden's example is
enough to help overcome resistance to
reform elsewhere there are cities from
New York to Los Angeles that are already
contemplating similarly bold action in
the city where George Floyd was killed
the Minneapolis City Council promised
last night to dismantle the police
department the Democrats in Congress
have proposed a bill of sweeping reforms
which would make it easier to punish
police misconduct and restricts the use
of deadly force as Americans from across
the country peacefully protest to demand
an end to injustice but the White House
is sending a very different message
Donald Trump's approach to policing has
always been the police should do
whatever they want and they should be as
tough as they can because they're the
good guys so my concern with Donald
Trump's behavior is that he has
essentially taken the federal government
out of the conversation about policing
and he is for states and localities to
take the nephilim themselves those
calling for change today can demand
action through the ballot box in
November I really do believe that we
collectively are gonna make a choice a
series of choices and we're gonna get to
decide the future that's in front of us
on reforms in public safety in the
future that's in front of us in terms of
how we're gonna treat some of our most
oppressed and most abused citizens it's
not something that's gonna happen to us
something we're gonna choose who they
choose from City Council all the way to
the White House could prove decisive in
the challenge of turning indignation
into legislation and enduring social
change I'm John fast Minh The Economist
Washington correspondent to see more of
our coverage of racial injustice in
America and across the world click the
link opposite thank you for watching
you